sí Él sigue rellenando en el fútbol
sudamericano este sábado flamengo se
impuso Atlético paranaense consiguió su
tercera Copa Libertadores la cuarta
consecutiva para un club del gigante
sudamericano vamos a analizar este
dominio de Brasil con Sara Castro y
directora de deportes de Caracol radio y
del diario vasra Hola Juan buenas noches
como siempre un gusto estar con ustedes
ahora vamos a comenzar hablando de ese
partido de esta final de flamengo contra
Atlético Atlético paranaense gana
flamengo que terminó jugando la segunda
parte con un hombre de más prácticamente
y pero atractivamente no fue un partido
muy vistoso hasta final de Copa
Libertadores sin duda un partido sin
brillo yo creo que esto también tiene
que ver con estas finales de solo 90
minutos no nosotros en Sudamérica
estamos acostumbrados a las finales de
ida y vuelta y que esto se juegue en un
territorio neutral creo que le falta
como ese sabor y ese picante que ponen
los hinchas en las ganaderías ahora
hablando del juego Creo que escolar y es
un técnico muy inteligente él sabía que
tenía que defender bien Y aprovechar y
terminar todas las jugadas eso fue lo
que intentó en los primeros minutos un
equipo que defendía que intentaba llegar
pero luego
empezó a ganar territorio
posicionalmente y esto complicó se
complica en el inicio en el final del
primer tiempo cuando resulta expulsado
Pedro Enrique a partir de ahí El dominio
de flamengo termina con una posesión de
76%, y Atlético paranaense intentando
que no se aumentará la ventaja creo que
esto tiene que ver con un proyecto
deportivo muy interesante que tiene
flamengo que ha logrado mantener una
idea futbolística en estos últimos años
y que por supuesto esto contando con
figuras del fútbol mundial que vinieron
de Europa es lo que hace que sean
imbatibles evidentemente no son las
finales que esperaríamos además hablando
de dos brasileros pero creo que es
típico de este tipo de partidos
definitivos en los que todo el mundo
quiere hacer eso por quedarse con la
copa además un estadio muy grande que no
se llenó completo transmite esa imagen
de vacío no tenemos aquí quizás la
cultura todavía de esos partidos únicos
como ya la hay en Europa hace mucho
tiempo centrándonos en el caso de
flamengo ya lo adelantabas a Sara
segunda Copa Libertadores en tres años
un proyecto muy definido Pero además un
proyecto que pasa el tiempo y sigue
mostrando que sigue siendo un caso de
éxito cómo lo hacen lo primero es
autoridad futbolística a partir de lo
que mencionaba creo que la idea de juego
se ha mantenido se suman figuras pero
siempre intentando ser un equipo
protagonista desde el juego es un equipo
que siempre y en todos los torneos que
participa suma muchos hombres al ataque
es un equipo que siempre Busca en poner
El dominio a través de eso no de un
equipo muy ofensivo un fútbol ofensivo y
esta idea la mantuvo dorival Junior
luego está el tema del mercado el
mercado brasilero sin duda es uno de los
más estables de Sudamérica con unos
ingresos que no tienen comparación en la
región Y eso hace que a nivel
competitivo pues maneje unos
presupuestos totalmente diferentes en el
caso de flamengo no solo con los premios
que ha logrado pero cuando uno mira sus
exportaciones de jugadores son
impresionantes ministros Juniors Lucas
paqueta jerson suman más de 100 millones
de dólares en ventas al extranjero
Entonces eso indica que las las finanzas
del club son buenas y que pueden
invertir en este tipo de proyectos
apuestan por equipos competitivos que
también sirvan de vitrina para exponer
estos nuevos jugadores un equipo como el
flamenco que ya gana esta Copa
Libertadores así de una manera
recurrente digamos cuál puede ser su
objetivo la copa digamos el Mundial de
Clubes que está un poco también en el
Limbo que no se me ocurre que otro
objetivo puede tener ya de manera
internacional siempre y ahora cuando
hablamos de fútbol sudamericano pensamos
en sí puede eliminar esa brecha con el
fútbol europeo Entonces el Mundial de
Clubes y sobre todo esta participación
del Real Madrid evocando lo que fue las
épocas esa final intercontinental creo
que es es ahí Hacia dónde vamos si es
posible entender como estos equipos con
unos presupuestos que aún no pueden
compararse los europeos pero que
evidentemente son más competitivos
pueden llegar a ganar este tipo de
partidos decisivos en ese escenario
mundial creo que esa sigue siendo la
deuda del fútbol sudamericano incluso
entendiendo que esta brecha se está
aumentando en Brasil versus el resto de
equipos los argentinos o sea entendiendo
que River fue el último argentino que
participó en una final de Copa
Libertadores los empieza a indicar que
estamos teniendo unos problemas de
brechas económicas que afectan el
rendimiento de la Copa Libertadores en
general no nos olvidamos de la Copa
Libertadores femenina el viernes
palmeiras le ganó a Boca Juniors doblete
palmeiras gana la Copa Libertadores
femenina flamengo gana la Copa
Libertadores masculina desde 2018 no
vemos a un campeón no brasileño en Las
Dos copas Brasil está aumentando su
dominio regional si El dominio tiene que
haber pues primero por supuesto con la
cantidad calidad de vuelos jugadores que
tienen tanto en la rama femenina como
masculina y de ahí digamos que esto es
histórico pero el desarrollo económico
también permite que los procesos en el
fútbol femenino se hayan adelantado a
los del a los de los otros países de la
conmebol Entonces esto implica que las
brasileras se impusieran Desde los
primeros ediciones de la Copa
Libertadores y que hayan mantenido ese
dominio sin embargo Ahora me parece muy
importante destacar lo que están
haciendo los equipos colombianos el
hecho de que tanto el deportivo Cali
Como el América llegarán a la semifinal
indica que algo está cambiando ya lo
hizo Atlético huila quedando campeón
América de Cali ha sido recurrente en
estas participaciones y ahí veíamos en
las imágenes Rodríguez que es una súper
jugadora y lo que está haciendo
Argentina que entró tarde y que todas
estas digamos disputas por el fútbol
femenino y que y que haya un desarrollo
equitativo en la región yo creo que
empieza a verse aquí una final Porque
además el primer tiempo fue muy
competitivo Boca Juniors versus
palmeiras Pero ellas ya con esas
condición y con una mayor sobre todo
competencia a nivel local creo que es
donde logran obtener estos resultados Yo
sé que por poco Nos quedamos sin
finalizar brasileña en esta edición de
la Copa Libertadores femenina Santiago
morning estuvo muy cerca de dar la
sorpresa contra palmeiras efectivamente
avance de Argentina avance de Colombia y
con un mundial el otro año mundial
femenino el Australia Nueva Zelanda ya
muy cerca avances muy interesantes los
de estos países